[Musique]
nous ne voulons plus que 1 président et
seul le droit de guerre ou de paix que
ce soit lui qui décide des plus grandes
lois ce que veulent les gilets jaunes ce
soit le peuple qui décide donc il faut
changer de constitution
il nous donne juste des miettes les 100
euros qui nous avait soi-disant promis
sainte alors oui mais pas d'autres donc
après moi je parle personnellement ma
leçon
le smic parce que voilà je le gagne et
son objet de travail à côté pour finir
en oeuvre le fins de mois la service
public public est considéré maintenant
comme une mini start up sexy un service
public n'est pas rentable
on doit le rendre rentable voilà c'est
la politique actuelle et ça c'est je
sais que ce gouvernement est là pour ça
pour la privatisation